[Music]
so we do a lot of
mi the [ __ ] and a lot of these uh
reddit posts
are about weddings and a lot of these
weddings are always through the lens
of a bridezilla or at least the the main
antagonist in these stories
are the bridezillas we're gonna do
husband zilla groomsmen family
oh groom's at all yeah in this case it's
kind of like a groomzilla
but you let me know okay definitely on
the i always wanted to know about more
groomzilla [ __ ] we have done one in the
past
i do remember one out of two thousand
bridesmaids i know there's so many true
question afterward that i've been uh to
[ __ ] ask
all right so am i the [ __ ] girl a
teenage girl
said that her dad or she said that she
ruined her dad's surprise wedding after
learning about the ceremony
30 minutes before hand huh so she
explains that
uh one day in january and for her to her
knowledge on this particular day as it
starts
she thinks it's just a regular day her
dad's gonna pick her up to spend the
week with him
uh just like any other you know dad week
so you know
her parents are separated right so she
didn't know that her dad wasn't getting
married that day
exactly and so he told her that they
were going to go for a drive
an hour away to a friend's house for a
surprise
party but once they arrived at the event
hall the dad informed her that it was
actually
his wedding surprise my party is the
surprise wedding getting married to
another lady
exactly that's not your mom he also told
her that she was one of the bridesmaids
and had to be
had to hurry inside so she could get
ready because the ceremony was before
it was set to start in 30 minutes oh my
gosh everything
is [ __ ] late you get ready for a
wedding in 30 minutes
no way so she goes i lost my [ __ ]
his wife's daughter and everyone else in
our family knew
for months but i was kept in the dark
because apparently
he was so sure that my mom would hear
about it and create drama
oh i felt extremely betrayed and lashed
out at my dad horribly
i was crying and said some very harsh
things
dude this guy is a [ __ ] hilarious
dude
i wonder if she even knew about the
girlfriend at all like the fiance
that's the point the surprise of getting
married i'm also in a relationship just
so you know
that's the most like guy thing ever my
god
and he probably did it as if like she
would have been
like oh she loves surprises bro that
would be like surprise honey i'm getting
married
she only needs 30 minutes to get ready
don't even worry about that why are you
so mad
what did i do like that's what he's
saying you love weddings right
you probably played it off like oh it's
not a big deal i mean she stays my
wedding yeah you know
she'd understand yeah yeah so [ __ ]
funny
by the way don't tell your mom is she
the only child uh
it comes off like she's the only child
um
so to continue uh she said she was
forced into the room
where she was supposed to get ready but
the dress was too small and wouldn't zip
up obviously you know she didn't go for
sizing
yeah like when you're using sizing yeah
dress fitting
dress fitting there we go i went to a
couple myself i pictured this dash
before you went to a wedding we'll talk
about it later off here
i'm off the record i pictured this dad
smoking a cigarette at a wedding store
and he's just like yeah she's about that
size yeah exactly she's like what are
you what are you a size what four
all right [ __ ] get one of those let's
do it it's probably way off
same cause maybe she told two that it
didn't zip
up that's an insult oh [ __ ] that's
compared to her last dress size when you
bought her like a halloween costume
which was like
five or something yeah i remember what
size it was
yeah she's a double zero for sure that's
what i said this is so [ __ ] hilarious
guys aren't the smartest creatures in
there no we are not hey i'm just glad
all this stuff is coming out of your
mouth
you know why it's so [ __ ] funny to us
it's because we can't deny
that this is some dad ass [ __ ] yeah yeah
this is something oh my god all see our
dad's doing this
and i see myself doing it you said it
yourself i see myself doing it
yeah sometimes you just want to avoid
conflict you know if you know the
the the mom of the you're how long has
that pandemic
avoiding conflict never pans out but for
some reason our guy brains
yeah thinks that we could get away with
it we'll sneak by this conflict
don't worry yourself and i'm thinking
that yeah and then it comes out being
ten times worse and blowing up in your
face
oh for sure like this like i know
exactly that's what i'm saying and then
you're like
i knew i should avoid a conflict even
more than i already did
i shouldn't have never had a wedding i
should have even invited her to my
wedding i wish you weren't even
[Laughter]
oh she's born [ __ ] up all right so
then uh to continue
at this point i threatened to call the
police if i wasn't taken back to my
mom's and me holy [ __ ]
my dad gave up and drove me back this
was 45 minutes after the ceremony time
by the time he got me home and went back
to his wedding it was almost three
hours past the wedding time the people
had left and i was told that he had to
marry his wife at the courts a week
later so they blew all their money and
they didn't get to have their fancy
lavish wedding and now they're just
how did the wife to be agreed i mean i
guess
maybe she didn't even know no yeah he
could have played everybody maybe that
but then also
i said i guess because then maybe she
feels like well i don't want to overstep
my boundaries
not her place not her place probably is
how she felt
but man this is such a dumb planet i'm
so i mean
laughing that it blew up in his face the
daughter also
she doesn't go with the flow
[Laughter]
like she ruined this she's entitled to
be pissed off
she made this all about herself dude
ridiculous she ain't down dude yeah yeah
yeah yeah
wait so how's this you gotta get a new
daughter dude
how's this groom zula not exact that's
what i said it's not exactly a groom
zillah situation but it's definitely
the guy's like situation
situation he's the monster he's writing
this the daughter the daughter's right
now and
is she like am i the not [ __ ] for
ruining their wedding pretty much yeah
or is
the dad the [ __ ] baby that's nice of
her to even think that she's no she's
not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh terrible that she even thinks that to
begin with that it's her fault for some
reason yeah
you know could she have acted you know
in a different way
maybe but you know but it is pretty
young to sit outside the wedding
she's a young kid she she caught off the
card
buy it you know so like was it is there
was there like not another option where
like everyone kind of gets to win
a little bit like if someone else in the
family could drop her off and take her
home
and then they could still have the
wedding the biggest problem is that he
brought her back
30 minutes before the wedding yeah there
should be a little more lightweight
there
a couple hours so then obviously she's
the one that not dressed for a wedding
she's in plain clothes and
if she went through the family is gonna
judge her on that and then be like oh
she didn't didn't even wear a dress
dude but then like how amazing of her to
even put on the [ __ ]
yes like she's trying yeah yeah but he's
the kind of dude that'll be like
women probably
he's talking to his friends dude you
wouldn't believe what my daughter did
dude she's such a little [ __ ]
bro big deal bro what's the [ __ ] big
deal so spoiled bro my daughter is such
a [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah just put on the damn
dress it goes so what if it doesn't zip
up it's only for 30 minutes
wow it's not about you this is my day
honey
okay that's why i should have had a son
it's your fault i wish you were a son
you read the
x chromosome yeah so the dad [ __ ]
idiot i love it so the dad has since
apologized but their relationship has
remained
strained however oh yeah
however relationship with her stepmother
and stepsister
which had been good in the past so they
they actually got along
uh is now non-existent oh no they're
blaming her too
uh or maybe they just don't talk anymore
oh maybe she's hurt because they did
know
i'm telling you bro weddings create
drama
so am i the [ __ ] for how i acted
i feel bad for his wife and had her and
had her wedding ruined
so i think
the what the dad threw on her was some
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
um maybe she could have dealt with it
differently but
also her feelings are pretty
legit dude like they're they're pretty
like i wouldn't know how to handle that
situation
but i think i would i'm just a different
person so i wouldn't handle it the same
way i'd just be like
ah [ __ ] it what's the best way to
maneuver
that's true yeah yeah i wouldn't have uh
done it that way either
but at the same time it's like as the
adult
it's your responsibility to handle it
way better yeah
seriously he [ __ ] up man 30 minutes at
least
at least yeah take longer than 30
minutes yeah but what if his dumb ass
was like why take about five and girls
they take a long time so what about 30
yeah yeah i'm gonna
times that by by five yeah that's plenty
of times
is a lot you know also he's so idiotic
too where it's like
how did he not give her time to get
ready right that's
the thing but then also he could have
his main fear was that he didn't want
the mom
to create more drama around the whole
wedding and stuff so it's like okay you
couldn't have a conversation with your
daughter
sure you're gonna [ __ ] leave it till
the day of your wedding but then
bring her on a few hours ahead have a
conversation let her know your fears
he's not a good person [ __ ]
reasonable yeah yeah
he doesn't i don't think he's the type
that thinks it through because i think
when he picked her up from school he's
already like this is gonna be so awesome
she loves surprises
from the sound of it maybe his ex-wife
isn't so dramatic from the sound of it
if he's always pulling stupid schemes
like this
she's just tired of his [ __ ] [ __ ]
right yeah so like
her marriage yeah it wasn't she wasn't
she doesn't cause drama maybe it's the
way he always handles [ __ ] right
who knows you know what he may not be
the best planner but he seems like a
pretty cool guy
he sounds like my kind of guy dude hit
me up
i want this guy in my life so i could
laugh at him
yeah yeah yeah like what else has he
come up with i know it's so funny
i bet i could like the way i'm picturing
him i bet that's exactly how he is in
real life
just just a total lie yeah this is gonna
be so sick i'm gonna pick up my daughter
check this out bro i'm gonna pick her up
she's not gonna have any idea and she
goes she loves her dude she loves her
why wouldn't she be excited can you
imagine all the dumbasses he has around
him
just saying the same [ __ ]
he's gonna be so excited dude we're
gonna have a carne asada spread it's
gonna be super
tight it's gonna be super quaint
dude we're gonna sell the house she grew
up in we saw all her toys and
so sick but it totally works out because
we're going to get her new [ __ ]
afterwards
it's all good it's a [ __ ] waiting
girls love surprises they love weddings
it's going to be [ __ ] awesome
yeah i do i totally think you should do
that that sounds awesome to me dude
you're a [ __ ] genius man that was
your daughter
i'd be so [ __ ] down for that oh shout
outs
like a merry good man
your wife is so lucky and that's their
bachelor party and start making out in
terms of the whole thing and it's just
like
it makes a lot of sense yeah dude yeah
i'm so trashy man
so one of the reddit responses was i can
understand your dad not wanting your mom
to find out assuming that his fears
about her making a scene was reasonable
however
he should have trusted you with the
information ahead of time so you were
not blindsided
so this guy is just he just [ __ ]
bitched out i feel like and also the
whole dress situation irks me so
much too but because it's like you lied
to her to drive over
to the event right why couldn't you lie
to her
months in advance to get the dress
fitting and say this is for a different
event
he's not a good planner he's not that
smart though
guys do things last minute yeah he seems
like a happy-go-lucky guy though yeah he
seems
he's like what's the big deal i feel
like he goes throughout life saying that
yeah what's the big deal man come on we
got rob what's the big deal we just buy
new things
she hit me up if you want to get some
brews dude let's go
i don't even drink
[Music]
you